la situation à bogotá comme celle d'un tony
abbott ou rapport je sais où c'est dur pour moi
hormones passées bogotá nous donne viltres
et porte grippe
la situation le centre pluriel dans
La Colombie
ouest
le pei acote de la lave de l'océan pacifique
juste et ne serait pas juste bien que variable
il a légué br mona pier en grande quantité
des forces armées et moi ml comme un où
Je l'ai armée avec plaisir pour diriger
façon la pacification qui s'est fatiguée
sur la peau la situation que le singe a traversée
à bogotá, ils ont donné naissance et un goya calice qui
dramatique est que le grand nombre de
jonas le cinéma de tournage
le biologiste de la police lui a dit
pacific se a la fonction du tout
monde
[Musique]
l'entourage national
Je connais la police que tu gonfles
sheen et léa et ça fait un c'est à comprendre
vidéo bbc et mods quand le de la
population civile à ceux qui roque et erp
c33
dans la communauté internationale de
répression si nous parvenons à la colombie 177
violé le cns qu'ils savent démontrer
paisible
contre la réforme qui vise il y a un autre
chose précisée que nous gouvernons je préside
iván duque a déclaré là-bas et le réseau gay
cette proposition zêta
de la réforme de la réforme fiscale ce
père quel père
herbón discute de l'argile, ils lui passent par tome
homme de sécurité cette association entre
pp et une autre raison de munt
que la réforme de l'hommage de ce père qui
thermos à air direct
la gare générale
ou est-ce que tu te regardes
Je pense que je mange la vie de la goutte
d'or que le radeau est dévoré on voit que
la ville d'arrivée des pauvres j'ai
colombien
delmon risk a rappelé que la colombie et
à 1000 et dépêchez-vous et je ne vais pas
Je m'ennuie d'un monde de la pauvreté est ancré
et parler minimum de corruption
ils auront probablement besoin de cpi pour
la jalousie comme les gris s'offrent que tu viennes et
Eh bien, oui, comment surgir les toiles considèrent
bernie civile
C'était la chance et le mauvais chemin du Vermont
en tant que colombien je pense que la la
possibilité de lire ce que vous préférez stocker
si fier pour porte este et julio le
mis de la pandémie a indiqué la vie qui est
aggravé a été livré en Colombie pour
que la situation se tarit être sofia et le
la terre et le müller et le bois des pauvres tu es
roy parle
lire le livre de la répression
en plus de la démission de prison
[Musique]
l'arme
a été l'arme de la continuité
donne lui du courage et de l'électro pour que
prendre sa retraite son por sol si la réforme va
calmer ma protestation et celle de
autre réforme qui est au niveau du laxatif
et a et vous est précédé de l'économique et
social kilian colom et quels sont-ils
agréable et en quantité cette personne
J'imaginais que la Colombie existait
manifestation
ré
[Musique]
bolivar 1
exact mobile je pense que pt 13 me fait
phrase principale comme colista mese infras
3 particulier en Amérique Latine de
twitter est espagnol et ils sont à vous
amérique latine bourg fait que ma voix me connaisse
voit ce dernier ton sa à une montagne
augmenter la protestation à la fois la fin
tant le pays n'a pas d'importance le système
politicien est d'aller vous y allez je lui ai demandé de
un plan libéralisme comme dogme
comme raison de là de l'économie sans
doute dans cpi la protestation
la manifestation est dure mais moi seul
m'a fait